Ajmal, can you hear me?
Ajmal，你能听到我说话吗？
Hello?
喂？
Yes, I can hear you.
能，我能听到。
OK, so are you still in front of the Canadian or not?
好的，你现在还在那个加拿大人前面吗？
Yeah, in front of the Canadian, in the water.
在的，在加拿大人前面，在水里。
You're in the water right now?
你现在在水里？
Yeah.
对。
This is a phone call between a man in California and a man standing in a canal outside the airport in Kabul, Afghanistan. That'll all make more sense in a minute. We had a totally different show planned for you today.
这是一个住在加利福尼亚州的男人与一个站在阿富汗喀布尔机场外运河里的男人之间的通话。过一会儿你们就会明白是怎么回事了。我们原本为今天安排了一档完全不同的节目。
But then, we came across this phone call. And it just seemed important to put it on the air now. It's from Monday, before the explosions around the airport that killed dozens of people.
但后来，我们偶然发现了这个通话。觉得现在把它播出来很重要。这是周一的通话，发生在机场周围发生爆炸、造成数十人死亡之前。
But it's a snapshot, in a way, from the last hours of this war, as the US leaves Afghanistan, when who would get out and who would not was all still being decided hour by hour. So what we're going to do on the show today is we're going to hear the story of that phone call. And then we're going to play you some other stories about getting out-- about people trying to extricate themselves from seemingly impossible situations.
但从某种程度上说，这是这场战争最后时刻的一个缩影，当时美国正在撤离阿富汗，谁能走、谁不能走，一切都在每小时不断变化。所以，我们今天节目要做的是，讲述这个电话背后的故事。然后，我们将播放其他关于“离开”的故事——讲述人们试图从看似不可能的绝境中脱身的故事。
So the first guy you heard on the call, the guy in California, is Kirk Johnson. We've had him on the show before. And when things started to fall apart in Afghanistan, he reached out to us, because years ago, he did reconstruction work in Iraq for the US government. And since then, for a long time now, he's been trying to get people in Iraq and Afghanistan who have worked with the US government and who are in danger out of those countries.
你刚才在通话中听到的第一个人，那个在加州的人，是柯克·约翰逊。我们以前邀请过他上节目。当阿富汗局势开始恶化时，他联系了我们，因为多年前他曾为美国政府在伊拉克做过重建工作。从那时起，很长一段时间以来，他一直试图帮助那些曾与美国政府合作、目前身处险境的伊拉克和阿富汗人离开这些国家。
He started an organization back in 2007 called The List Project. So these past weeks, Kirk has been on the phone constantly. And on Monday night, with his kids asleep in the other room, he had this series of phone calls which he recorded with the man you heard. His name is Ajmal.
他在2007年创办了一个名为“名单计划”（The List Project）的组织。所以过去几周，柯克一直在不停地接打电话。周一晚上，孩子们在另一个房间睡着后，他与你刚才听到的那个人进行了一系列通话，并录了音。那人的名字叫Ajmal。
And Kirk is trying to talk him through the crowds, and the confusion, and chaos around the airport in Afghanistan to try to get Ajmal and his family past all the barriers, hopefully onto a plane and out of the country. All of this is happening over the phone from half a world away. Nancy Updike here has known Kirk for many years. She talked to him about what happened. Here's Nancy.
柯克试图引导他穿过阿富汗机场周围的人群、困惑和混乱，设法让Ajmal一家越过所有障碍，希望能登上飞机离开这个国家。所有这一切都是通过电话在半个地球之外进行的。南希·厄普代克认识柯克很多年了。她和柯克聊了聊当时的情况。接下来是南希。
Kirk didn't know Ajmal before Monday night. He never met him. He just heard this was a person who needed help-- one of the many people who needed help, whose names have been piling up in these threads Kirk has been on all week-- group chats with US veterans, active military, current and former diplomats and aid workers, some Afghan citizens of the US and other countries, all on their phones day and night, trying to help Afghans get out.
柯克在周一晚上之前并不认识Ajmal。他从未见过他。他只是听说这个人需要帮助——这是众多需要帮助的人之一，他们的名字在柯克整周参与的那些群聊中堆积如山——那是与美国退伍军人、现役军人、现任和前任外交官及援助人员，以及一些美国和其他国家的阿富汗公民建立的群组，他们日夜守在电话旁，试图帮助阿富汗人离开。
Ajmal, can you hear me?
Ajmal，你能听到我说话吗？
Monday night, Kirk called Ajmal.
周一晚上，柯克给Ajmal打了电话。
I can hear you.
我能听到。
OK, so are you still in front of the Canadian, or not?
好的，你现在还在那个加拿大人前面吗？
Yeah, in front of the Canadian, in the water.
在的，在加拿大人前面，在水里。
You're in the water right now?
你现在在水里？
Yes.
是的。
The Canadian is a Canadian soldier, and the water is the canal right outside the Kabul airport.
“加拿大人”指的是一名加拿大士兵，“水”是喀布尔机场外的一条运河。
[? This ?] is not [INAUDIBLE], don't know--
[？这个？]不是[听不清]，不知道——
The only thing Ajmal is trying to do here, the whole thing, is to slog his way to within earshot of the one Canadian soldier he can see and make himself heard above the crowd.
Ajmal在这里所做的唯一一件事，就是拼命挪动到他所能看到的那个加拿大士兵的听力范围内，并确保在人群的嘈杂声中能让人听到他的声音。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声嘈杂]
Canada!
加拿大！
Ajmal worked for an NGO funded by the United States. And now, he and his family need to leave-- him, his parents, and his brother. They're luckier than most of the people around them, because they have citizenship in another country. He and his family are all Canadian citizens.
Ajmal曾为一个由美国资助的非政府组织工作。现在，他和他的家人——他、他的父母和他的兄弟——需要离开。他们比周围的大多数人幸运，因为他们拥有另一个国家的公民身份。他和他的家人都是加拿大公民。
And please picture this young Canadian, Ajmal. Kirk sent me a photo of him in the canal. Ajmal is 27 years old. Pretty sure he could pass for 19 without his goatee.
请想象一下这个年轻的加拿大人Ajmal。柯克发给我一张他在运河里的照片。Ajmal今年27岁。我敢肯定，如果不留山羊胡子，他看起来就像19岁。
He's slight, big glasses, wearing his backpack in front of him on his chest, like a nervous tourist. He is knee-deep in water. On one side of the canal is a growing crowd of Afghans. On the other are soldiers. And behind the soldiers is the path to get into the airport.
他身材瘦小，戴着一副大眼镜，像个紧张的游客一样把背包背在胸前。他站在及膝深的水里。运河的一边是越来越多的人群，另一边是士兵。而在士兵身后，就是进入机场的通道。
Do-- do you know their name, or no?
你——你知道他们的名字吗，或者不知道？
The-- no. The soldier's name? No.
那个——不。士兵的名字？不知道。
Please wait, OK?
请等一下，好吗？
OK, I'm waiting.
好的，我在等。
Exactly how Ajmal came to be standing in a canal is, hours earlier, he'd received an email with instructions for what to do, how to get out. He forwarded the email to Kirk.
Ajmal到底是怎么站到运河里的呢？几个小时前，他收到了一封邮件，里面有关于怎么做、怎么撤离的说明。他把这封邮件转发给了柯克。
Here's the email that Ajmal got at 3:01 AM from-- from the Canadian government.
这是Ajmal在凌晨3:01收到的来自——来自加拿大政府的邮件。
Kirk read the key part.
柯克读了其中的关键部分。
Important instructions-- go to The Baron Hotel immediately-- all caps. Do not wear Western style clothing-- all caps. Be prepared to wait for many hours. Once inside, go to the garden and sit under the Canadian flag and wait for Canadian officials. Bring food and water, if possible.
重要指示——立即前往男爵酒店（The Baron Hotel）——全大写。不要穿西式服装——全大写。做好等待数小时的准备。一旦进入，请到花园坐在加拿大国旗下面，等待加拿大官员。如果可能，带上食物和水。
That's the official process here. Get yourself to a hotel garden, sit down under a flag. Do this immediately somehow. Bring water. Ajmal and his family had gone to the place they thought was The Baron Hotel, but it was the wrong place. No Canadian officials they could see-- seemed to be all British people.
这就是这里的官方程序。设法赶到酒店花园，坐在国旗下面。无论如何立即照做。带上水。Ajmal一家去了他们以为是男爵酒店的地方，但地点错了。他们看不到任何加拿大官员——看起来全是英国人。
So Kirk drew a map, looking at Google Maps, with the route Ajmal, his parents, and his brother needed to take, through more crowds, to get to the right place. The canal, believe it or not, was the right place-- or as close as they were able to get. The canal is next to The Baron Hotel.
于是柯克看着谷歌地图画了一张路线图，指引Ajmal、他的父母和兄弟需要穿过更多的人群到达正确的地方。信不信由你，运河就是那个正确的地方——或者说是他们能到达的最接近的地方。运河就在男爵酒店旁边。
And there was a Canadian soldier there. They could see him. He had a little Canadian flag on his uniform. But he kept stepping away.
那里有一个加拿大士兵。他们能看到他。他的制服上有一个小小的加拿大国旗。但他一直在走开。
OK, is he back?
好的，他回来了吗？
Yeah, they are talking with the [INAUDIBLE].
是的，他们正在和[听不清]谈话。
He's talking to someone else right now?
他现在正在和别人说话吗？
He's talking with someone else. I'm waiting for him.
他正在和别人说话。我在等他。
OK. Jesus Christ.
天哪。
Ajmal is trying to get the soldier's attention, because, as I keep saying, Ajmal is a citizen of Canada. He is not a supplicant. He has the right papers. But Ajmal, who comes across as a cautious, rule-following sort of person, with his face mask pulled neatly under his chin in case he's ever inside again, that young man is stuck in a canal.
Ajmal正试图引起那个士兵的注意，因为我一直在说，Ajmal是加拿大公民。他不是乞求者。他有合法的证件。但是Ajmal，一个看起来谨慎、遵守规则的人，口罩整齐地拉在下巴下面以防万一再次进入室内，那个年轻人被困在运河里了。
I'll be patient. Don't--
我会耐心的。别——
Excuse me? Hey, Canada? Canada?
打扰一下？嘿，加拿大？加拿大？
Oh my god.
天哪。
Other people in this same situation might have no trouble bellowing to get someone's attention. Soft-spoken Ajmal is saying, excuse me, excuse me, Canada? The soldier is talking to other people or walking even further away. Ajmal asks Kirk what words he should be calling out.
处境相同的人可能毫无顾忌地大喊以引起别人的注意。说话轻声细语的Ajmal一直在说：打扰一下，打扰一下，加拿大？士兵在和别人说话，或者走得更远了。Ajmal问柯克他应该喊什么词。
What's a good word to call them? Because they're a bit far.
有什么好的词可以喊他们吗？因为他们离得有点远。
When you You get an opportunity, Ajmal, OK-- can you hear me?
当你有机会的时候，Ajmal，好的——你能听到我说话吗？
Then I call you?
然后我再喊你？
No, I'm going to stay on the line with you. When he finishes with this guy, you need to say that there is a friend of a Canadian minister on the phone. Can you--
不，我会一直和你保持通话。当他结束和那个人的谈话时，你需要说电话里有一位加拿大部长的朋友。你能——
OK, OK, OK.
好的，好的，好的。
OK? A friend of a Canadian minister on the phone.
好的吗？电话里有一位加拿大部长的朋友。
It's true. Kirk, through his wife, is friends with a Canadian member of parliament, a minister, who, at that point, was fast asleep and had no idea this was happening. Kirk is trying to think of anything he can tell Ajmal to say to get the soldier's attention. Namedropping? Yes, sure, definitely.
这是真的。柯克通过他的妻子，确实认识一位加拿大国会议员，一位部长。那时那个人正在熟睡，根本不知道发生了什么。柯克试图想出任何他能告诉Ajmal的话，以引起士兵的注意。套近乎？是的，当然，肯定。
[? Yes, ?] [? just-- ?] just a minute.
[？是的，？][？只要——？]等一分钟。
Where is he?
他在哪？
Uh, he left [INAUDIBLE]. I'm waiting for him.
呃，他离开了[听不清]。我在等他。
OK, I don't want you to just say Canada. I want you to say, I'm a Canadian citizen.
好的，我不希望你只喊加拿大。我要你喊，我是加拿大公民。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
He doesn't know me. He's putting trust in me. I don't know him. I've already pushed him to fight through the crowd and jump into the canal.
他不认识我。他信任我。我也不认识他。我已经推着他穿过人群跳进运河里了。
That was your idea, to get in the canal?
那是你的主意，让他进运河？
Yes.
是的。
Huh.
嗯。
By the time of that phone call, that was already-- when he got to the back end of that crowd and saw thousands of people, he said, there's-- I can't do this. There's no-- I have my parents here. We can't get to the front. We're just going to have to try another day, or wait for you to work your connections to get the Canadians to come out and find us.
在那个通话的时候，这已经是——当他到达人群的后方看到成千上万的人时，他说，我做不到。这里没有——我的父母在这里。我们无法到达前面。我们只能改天再试，或者等你通过人脉让加拿大人出来找我们。
And I told him-- this is over text-- but I was like, they're not going to come out for you. You have to push through that crowd. And his sister was on the thread, and a couple other people who had been trying to help him.
我告诉他——这是通过短信说的——我说，他们不会出来找你的。你必须推开人群穿过去。他的妹妹也在群里，还有其他几个一直试图帮助他的人。
And they were messaging me, saying, go easy on him. He was in the hospital last week with a panic attack. You know, they were basically saying, he's already at the breaking point.
他们给我发信息说，对他好点。他上周因为惊恐发作进了医院。你知道，他们基本上是在说，他已经到了崩溃的边缘。
But I knew that, if he couldn't get within earshot of a Canadian soldier, he had-- there was nothing. Not knowing, if he gives up today, whether or not the doors will be completely shut tomorrow. And the other thing that is weighing on me, but that I'm not telling him, is this dread of one rogue Talib opening fire into that crowd, one IED going off in that crowd.
但我知道，如果他不能进入加拿大士兵的听力范围内，他就——什么都没有了。不知道如果他今天放弃，明天门是否会完全关闭。还有一件事让我很担心，但我没有告诉他，那就是恐惧会有塔利班分子向人群开火，或者人群中发生爆炸。
Less than 24 hours after we talked, a bomb was detonated outside the airport. And someone started shooting into the crowd.
在我们通话不到24小时后，机场外发生了炸弹爆炸。有人开始向人群射击。
So everything came down to trying to get him in the right point on Earth where his voice would be loud enough to be heard, and strong enough to be listened to.
所以一切归结于试图把他送到地球上正确的位置，让他的声音足够大，能够被听到，足够有力，能够被倾听。
You are in the right position.
你现在处于正确的位置了。
But I think they are leaving.
但我认为他们要离开了。
What-- what do you-- OK.
什么——你——好的。
I think they're leaving the spot. Please, please talk to them.
我想他们要离开那个位置了。求求你，求求你和他们说话。
You have-- you have to shout, I'm a Canadian citizen. Do it right now, if you see them.
你必须——你必须大喊，我是加拿大公民。如果你看到他们，马上做。
Canadian!
加拿大！
Not, Canadian. Say, Canadian citizen. You can't just say Canadian, Ajmal. You have to say Canadian citizen.
不是加拿大，说，加拿大公民。你不能只说加拿大，Ajmal。你必须说加拿大公民。
I'll call them.
我会叫他们的。
OK.
好的。
Canadian citizen!
加拿大公民！
Keep saying that.
继续喊那个。
Canadian citizen!
加拿大公民！
[BLEEP]
[消音]
If you have sharp ears, you can hear Kirk swearing under his breath all during this call, basically cursing his way through the stress.
如果你耳朵尖的话，可以听到柯克在整个通话过程中一直在低声咒骂，基本上是通过咒骂来缓解压力。
What's happening?
发生了什么？
I think the [INAUDIBLE] is increasing. I don't know what's happening.
我想[听不清]在增加。我不知道发生了什么。
He's saying the crowd is increasing. It's increasing.
他说人群在增加。在增加。
The crowds are increasing.
人群在增加。
I know.
我知道。
--crowd is increasing [INAUDIBLE]--
——人群在增加[听不清]——
I know, but you are in the right-- you are in the right position. You can't give up right now. You--
我知道，但你在正确的位置——你就在正确的位置。你现在不能放弃。你——
OK, so I am inside, so-- but my family is down. They are-- they are back.
好的，我现在在里面，所以——但我的家人在下面。他们——他们在后面。
OK. [GROANS] How far away are they?
好的。[呻吟声]他们离你有多远？
Kirk is groaning, because he didn't realize Ajmal was separated from his family, his parents, and his brother at this point. Even if they're not that far away right now, while Ajmal and Kirk are focused on connecting with this soldier, Ajmal's family could get pushed out of sight as the crowd keeps swelling and pushing forward. A bad scenario would be Ajmal ends up getting out, but his family stays lost in the throng.
柯克在呻吟，因为他没意识到Ajmal此时已经与家人、父母和兄弟分开了。即使他们现在离得不远，当Ajmal和柯克专注于与那个士兵联系时，Ajmal的家人可能会随着人群不断涌动和推进而消失在视线之外。最坏的情况是Ajmal成功出去了，但他的家人却迷失在人群中。
On these group threads, these chats Kirk is following, they are full of stories of family members getting separated. Ajmal hadn't wanted to bring his parents and his brother into this gross canal unless it was clear they were going to get out. He said the bottom of the canal had these slippery stones, and he worried one of his parents would fall and injure themselves. Now there's no time for Ajmal to break off and go get them. He has to keep trying to reach this soldier.
在这些群聊中，柯克关注的那些聊天记录里，全是家人失散的故事。Ajmal不想带父母和兄弟进这条恶心的运河，除非能确保他们能离开。他说运河底部有湿滑的石头，他担心父母中的一人会摔倒受伤。现在Ajmal没时间分身去接他们了。他必须继续努力接触那个士兵。
You can't lose that spot. You have that-- you had that soldier right in front of you. He's going to come back.
你不能失去那个位置。你有那个——你刚才就在那个士兵面前。他会回来的。
So here-- he's so far. I think it's impossible. Is there any other way?
所以这里——他太远了。我觉得这不可能。还有其他办法吗？
You have to stay in that spot and wait for him to come back. The fact that you just sent me that picture--
你必须待在那个位置，等他回来。你刚才发给我的那张照片，事实就是——
I'll wait-- yeah, I'm waiting.
我会等的——是的，我在等。
OK.
好的。
So I will call you back, OK?
所以我再给你打电话，好吗？
Call me back as soon as he gets close, OK?
他一靠近就再给我打电话，好吗？
OK, OK, OK.
好的，好的，好的。
Just in case anyone is finding their ire at this point focused on Canada, I want to state the obvious and say that, in the big picture, this was our show, the United States-- our plans, our timeline. Those were dictating the overall scene at the airport. Ajmal and Kirk got back on the phone. They'd been at it for almost six hours.
以防有人此时对加拿大心生愤恨，我想陈述一个显而易见的事实：从大局来看，这是我们美国人的节目——我们的计划，我们的时间表。这些主导了机场的整体局面。Ajmal和柯克重新接通了电话。他们已经这样持续了近六个小时。
Do not let him go away without saying, you're a Canadian citizen, and a minister is on the phone.
不要让他走开，一定要说，你是加拿大公民，而且一位部长在电话里。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声嘈杂]
A long minute goes by where Kirk can't tell what's happening.
漫长的一分钟过去了，柯克看不出发生了什么。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声嘈杂]
Ajmal keeps asking him, please wait, please wait.
Ajmal一直请求他，请等一下，请等一下。
Please wait here.
请在这里等一下。
Don't-- don't worry about me. Just do not let him leave without saying what I told you.
别——别担心我。只要在他走之前说出我告诉你的那些话就行。
Another half minute. Ajmal is fighting off despair. The soldier isn't responding to him.
又过了半分钟。Ajmal正在努力抵御绝望。士兵没有回应他。
So he is not responding, he just told me.
所以他没有回应，他刚才告诉我的。
What did you say?
你说什么？
He is so [INAUDIBLE].
他太[听不清]了。
Are you still close to him?
你还在他附近吗？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声嘈杂]
Another agonizing minute and a half--
又过了痛苦的一分半钟——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声嘈杂]
--and then suddenly--
——然后突然——
Ajmal, can you hear me?
Ajmal，你能听到我说话吗？
Hello?
喂？
Hello, who is this?
喂，你是谁？
Hello?
喂？
Yes, who am I talking to?
是的，我在和谁说话？
Who's this?
你是谁？
This is Kirk Johnson. I've served with USAID in Iraq--
我是柯克·约翰逊。我曾在伊拉克服役于美国国际开发署——
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
--sorry, can you hear me?
——抱歉，你能听到我说话吗？
Yes, I can hear you.
是的，我能听到。
OK, you have four Canadian citizens there. I'm calling on behalf of Mélanie Joly, who is a minister of economic development for Canada. You have four Canadian citizens. They were asked to go in there right now. And they've been pushed back several times so far.
好的，你有四名加拿大公民在那里。我是代表加拿大经济发展部部长梅拉妮·乔利（Mélanie Joly）打电话的。你有四名加拿大公民。他们被要求立即进入那里。而且到目前为止他们已经被推回去好几次了。
Yeah, we're going to process them. In the meantime, there's a lot of people here. We will process them, OK?
是的，我们会处理他们的。同时，这里有很多人。我们会处理他们的，好吗？
I understand, but I just need your assurance that they're going to get through, because one of the group is in poor health. And I know that Mélanie Joly is--
我明白，但我只需要你的保证他们能进去，因为其中一人健康状况不佳。而且我知道梅拉妮·乔利正在——
Yeah, yeah, we will--
是的，是的，我们会——
--she's-- the minister is wanting-- she wants it--
——她——部长想要——她想要——
They will get through. They just--
他们会进去的。他们只是——
I need to be able to tell the minister that they're through.
我需要能够告诉部长他们已经进去了。
Yeah, I understand what you're saying, sir. I'm going to look at his paperwork, and they will be able to get through, OK?
是的，我明白你的意思，先生。我会看一下他的文件，他们就能进去的，好吗？
OK, I'm going to stay on the line. Thank you for doing that, sir. I appreciate it.
好的，我会保持通话。谢谢你这样做，先生。我很感激。
--need to be patient. It's--
——需要耐心。这是——
I know-- I know you got your hands full.
我知道——我知道你手头有很多工作。
--pretty hectic here, so we have to be patient, OK?
——这里很忙乱，所以我们必须耐心，好吗？
I know. I'll tell them to say--
我知道。我会告诉他们要说——
Tell them to be patient.
告诉他们要耐心。
I'm grateful to you for your help, sir. Thank you.
我很感激你的帮助，先生。谢谢。
OK. I'll give him the phone back.
好的。我会把电话还给他。
OK, I'm going to stay on the line.
好的，我会保持通话。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
It's not clear if the Canadian minister gambit carried any sway with this soldier. He mostly sounds like he wanted to get off the phone and get back to work. But Ajmal finally had his attention.
尚不清楚加拿大部长的计策是否对这个士兵产生了影响。他听起来更像是想挂断电话回去工作。但Ajmal终于引起了他的注意。
And what a frightening degree of perseverance it took Ajmal to get to this point, where he could just hand someone his papers. And even perseverance most likely wouldn't have been enough without luck, without connections to these groups Kirk and others are part of, or to someone else with power. How many people in the crowd around Ajmal had perseverance, even courage, but none of the luck?
Ajmal为了到达这一步需要多么令人恐惧的毅力，他才能把证件交给某人。即便如此，如果没有运气，没有与柯克等人所属的这些群组的联系，或者没有与某个有权势的人的联系，毅力很可能是不够的。在Ajmal周围的人群中，有多少人有毅力，甚至勇气，却没有任何运气？
OK, Ajmal--
好的，Ajmal——
Hello?
喂？
Yeah, can you hear me?
是的，你能听到我说话吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK, get your family close to you. OK? I don't care--
好的，让你的家人靠近你。好的吗？我不在乎——
Tell my family to come?
告诉我的家人过来？
Tell-- tell them to come. You may have to wait a while, but do not-- do not be separate from them now.
告诉——告诉他们过来。你可能需要等一会儿，但不要——不要现在和他们分开。
Yes.
是的。
Do not move where you are, OK?
不要离开你所在的地方，好吗？
OK, thank you, sir.
好的，谢谢你，先生。
OK.
好的。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
Kirk and I did this interview a day and a half after this call with Ajmal ended. And Kirk was still waiting to hear if Ajmal and his family made it out. Then, finally, he got a text from him. It came through as Kirk and I were finishing up our interview.
在Ajmal的那个电话结束后一天半，我和柯克进行了这次采访。柯克仍在等待Ajmal和他的家人是否成功离开的消息。然后，他终于收到了一条短信。当我和柯克结束采访时，短信传了过来。
He texted me-- hang on-- oh my god.
他给我发了短信——等等——噢天哪。
What?
什么？
They just got on a plane. They're--
他们刚刚登上了一架飞机。他们——
Ajmal and his family, they're on a plane?
Ajmal和他的家人，他们在飞机上？
Yes.
是的。
There's one part of Ajmal's story that took Kirk's breath away, even in the retelling. It was the way Ajmal ended up finding his brother after he'd made contact with the soldier, because Ajmal's family, as Kirk had feared, had gotten lost in the crowd.
Ajmal故事里有一个部分让柯克屏住呼吸，即使在复述时也是如此。那就是Ajmal在联系到那个士兵后找到他兄弟的方式，因为正如柯克所担心的，Ajmal的家人已经在人群中走散了。
You don't have to have brothers to feel this, but my brothers are my best friends. And the way that I subsequently found out he was able to-- to get them was that he just called from the canal into this crowd, asking his fellow Afghans to start calling his brother's name. And they all started shouting it out. And that's how they found his-- his brother and parents. And so they then got into the canal from there and joined him.
你不需要有兄弟也能感受到这一点，但我的兄弟是我最好的朋友。后来我发现他能够——找到他们的方法是，他就在运河里对着人群大喊，请求他的阿富汗同胞开始呼喊他兄弟的名字。他们都开始大声喊叫。那就是他们找到他——他的兄弟和父母的方式。于是他们从那里进了运河并和他汇合了。
You know, like, I want to feel-- I want to feel like, proud about this, and feel like this is a good story. But it's just-- there's so much more suffering that has happened, and people that aren't getting through. I don't want people who hear this to think that-- you know, people who are sort of discomfited by what they're hearing about this, who may not really be close to the situation or understand what's going on, to be like, oh, hey, I heard it's bad, but hey, all right, good. Now, this guy-- this has a happy ending.
你知道，就像，我想感到——感到骄傲，觉得这是一个好故事。但这只是——发生了太多太多的苦难，还有很多人没能过去。我不希望听到这个故事的人认为——你知道，那些对他们所听到的事情感到不安的人，那些可能并不了解情况或不明白发生了什么的人，会觉得，哦，嘿，我听说情况很糟糕，但嘿，好吧，太好了。现在，这个人——这有一个圆满的结局。
This has a happy ending for this guy and his family, and for a small percentage of the lucky few that are getting through. I-- I fear that we're-- you know, we're not going to really see the full toll of this when this is all over. And we're-- we're just about at the end of this whole disaster, and at the start of something much darker, I fear.
这对他和他的家人，以及少数幸运通过的幸运儿来说，是一个圆满的结局。我——我担心我们——你知道，当这一切结束时，我们真的无法看到全部的代价。而且我们——我们正处于整个灾难的尾声，但我担心，我们正处于一个更加黑暗的开端。
I fear that, too.
我也担心这一点。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, some of our favorite stories we've run about getting out, including a choose your own adventure story about getting out of a relationship. Yeah, choose your own adventure on the radio, somehow. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，我们将分享一些关于“离开”的我们最喜欢的故事，包括一个关于从一段关系中脱身的“选择你自己的冒险”故事。是的，某种程度上，广播里的“选择你自己的冒险”。稍后节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm David Kestenbaum, in for Ira Glass. This week on our show, getting out-- stories of people making it out of seemingly impossible situations, or trying to, anyway.
这是《美国生活》。我是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆，代班艾拉·格拉斯。本周我们的节目主题是“离开”——讲述人们从看似不可能的绝境中脱身的故事，或者至少是在尝试脱身的故事。
Act two-- You Can Check Out Any Time You Like, But You Can Never Leave. So one of the things about trying to get out of an intense situation is that it can feel like every little decision you make might take you down the wrong path. Back when she was a teenager, one of our co-workers, Elna Baker, found herself in that position.
第二幕——“你可以随时结账，但你永远无法离开”。关于试图从激烈的情况下脱身的一件事是，你可能会觉得你做的每一个小决定都可能让你走上错误的道路。回到她十几岁的时候，我们的同事埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）就处于那个境地。
She was trapped in a hotel room with her siblings, held there by a stranger. What happened was, their family was all staying at this Marriott. But they're such a big family that the parents and the oldest kid were in one room. Elna and the three other kids were next door in their own room.
她被困在酒店房间里，和她的兄弟姐妹在一起，被一个陌生人扣押在那里。发生的事情是，他们全家都住在万豪酒店。但他们是一个大家庭，所以父母和最大的孩子住在一个房间。埃尔娜和另外三个孩子住在隔壁的房间里。
There was Elna, who was 14 at the time, Julia, who was 10, Briton, who was eight, and Jill, who was five. Elna was sharing a bed with her. Elna, who was in eighth grade at the time, was more or less in charge.
当时14岁的埃尔娜，10岁的朱莉娅，8岁的布里顿和5岁的吉尔。埃尔娜和她同睡一张床。当时读八年级的埃尔娜或多或少负责照顾他们。
And then one night, they're all asleep. It's the middle of the night. She told this all to Ira.
然后有一天晚上，他们都睡着了。那是深夜。她把这一切告诉了艾拉。
My memory is that-- it's like-- I saw like, a sliver of light, which is what woke me up, and the sound of the door closing. And there was the feeling that there was someone standing at the foot of the bed.
我的记忆是——那就像——我看到了一线光，那是把我叫醒的东西，还有门关上的声音。有一种感觉，床脚站着一个人。
Mhm.
嗯。
So I reached over, and I turned the lamp on. And there was this woman.
所以我伸手打开了灯。那里站着一个女人。
Wow.
哇。
And she looked startled to see us. And the first thing she said was, you're just children. I didn't expect you to be children.
她看到我们时显得很惊讶。她说的第一句话是，你们只是孩子。我没想到你们是孩子。
So that's pretty creepy.
那真是令人毛骨悚然。
Right.
对。
What did you make of her saying that?
你对她说那句话怎么看？
I instantly felt like this is an unsafe situation.
我立刻感觉到这是一个不安全的情况。
Yeah. Describe her.
是的。描述一下她。
I remember she was my mom's age. So she was probably in her 40s.
我记得她和我妈妈年纪差不多。所以她可能40多岁。
Mhm.
嗯。
And brown hair, white, kind of like, frumpy-looking, like somebody you'd sit next to on the bus or something.
棕色头发，白人，看起来有点邋遢，就像你坐在公共汽车旁边的人一样。
Did she seem menacing?
她看起来有威胁性吗？
She seemed really distressed. She was crying, too.
她看起来真的很痛苦。她也在哭。
She was crying?
她在哭？
She was crying, yeah. She cried the whole time she was there.
她在哭，是的。她在那里的整个过程中一直在哭。
She's crying, and she said, you're children. I didn't expect you to be children.
她在哭，她说，你们是孩子。我没想到你们是孩子。
Yeah.
对。
And do the other kids get up?
其他孩子醒了吗？
Everyone's wide awake. I distinctly remember my little brothers' and sisters' faces, because their eyes were just huge. But no one said anything.
所有人都完全清醒了。我清楚地记得我弟弟妹妹们的脸，因为他们的眼睛睁得很大。但没有人说话。
And are they sitting up, too, or are they just laying flat still?
他们也坐起来了吗，还是仍然平躺着？
They're still laying flat. Nobody moved.
他们仍然平躺着。没人动。
So what happens next?
那么接下来发生了什么？
She's talking, right? This isn't how it was supposed to be. And she's also crying. And she's talking to herself. I remember it being very hard to follow what she was saying.
她在说话，对吧？事情本不该是这样的。而且她也在哭。她在自言自语。我记得很难听懂她在说什么。
Yeah.
对。
And eventually, I said, I'm sorry, I think you have the wrong room. And she started to cry. And she said, I know, I know. I do this, I do this. I don't know why I do this.
最后，我说，对不起，我想你走错房间了。她开始哭。她说，我知道，我知道。我做了这个，我做了这个。我不知道为什么我这么做。
And then she's pacing back and forth, and kind of crying. And she sits down on the bed, at the foot of the bed.
然后她在来回走动，一边哭。她在床脚坐了下来。
Did she seem crazy, or did she seem upset?
她看起来很疯狂，还是看起来很难过？
I mean, it's interesting. I was-- I think I-- I was too young and unfamiliar to identify what a crazy person seems like.
意思是，这很有趣。我当时——我想我——我太年轻，不熟悉什么是疯狂。
Yeah.
对。
But what I could identify in that moment was that this person was unpredictable.
但我当时能识别出的是，这个人是不可预测的。
So you guys were like, oh, I've got to be really careful how I do this.
所以你们像，哦，我必须非常小心我怎么做。
I remember feeling that pressure, and in that moment, very, very, very aware of my brothers and sisters, because they were so little. And--
我记得那种压力，那一刻，非常非常清醒地意识到我的弟弟妹妹们，因为他们太小了。而且——
Yeah.
对。
--that something bad could happen to them. And that the way that it wasn't going to happen to them was me. There were no adults there. I think it was the first situation I was ever in where there was-- you couldn't defer to someone else to keep you safe or tell you what to do. And what do I do?
——坏事可能会发生在他们身上。而能阻止坏事发生在他们身上的就是我。那里没有成年人。我认为这是我第一次遇到这种情况，没有——你不能指望别人来保护你或告诉你该怎么做。我该怎么办？
And it had that quality of like-- like, time slows down. And you're kind of-- you're there, but you're also watching. And so then, I did the math in my head. And I was like, OK, I have a couple options. They are cry for help, scream. But I don't think anyone will hear.
它有一种感觉，像——时间变慢了。你有一种——你身处其中，但也像在看戏。于是，我在脑子里计算了一下。我想，好的，我有几个选择。大声求救，尖叫。但我不认为有人会听到。
Mhm.
嗯。
I remember looking at how far away the phone was from me.
我记得看了一眼电话离我有多远。
Mhm.
嗯。
And I realized I can reach and grab the phone, and I could call for help. Or even like, if I could knock on the door where my sister was--
我意识到我可以伸手去拿电话，我可以求救。或者甚至，如果我能敲隔壁我姐姐的门——
Sister in the connecting room next door.
在隔壁连通房的姐姐。
I could at least-- they would know something was happening in here. And they could get to us in time.
我至少——她们会知道这里发生了什么。她们可以及时过来。
Yeah.
对。
But all of that felt like an escalation, like I would provoke her. And so what can I do to not provoke her and kind of play up the fact that we're children? And what I felt I needed to do was I needed to calm her down and become her friend. And if I could become her friend, she would leave, and she wouldn't hurt us.
但这感觉像升级，好像我会激怒她。所以我能做什么不激怒她，并利用我们是孩子的事实？我感觉我需要做的是，我需要让她平静下来，成为她的朋友。如果我能成为她的朋友，她就会离开，她就不会伤害我们。
Like, get her to see you as a person?
像，让她把你视为一个人？
Just make her think I was on her side. Because then-- it didn't feel like she didn't see us as people. It just felt like-- it felt dangerous, and I didn't understand why. And I felt like the key to being safe was slowing everything down.
只是让她认为我和她是同一边的。因为那时——感觉并不是她没把我们看作人。只是感觉——感觉很危险，我不明白为什么。我感觉安全的关键是让一切慢下来。
And I remember her saying, I'm really sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry I'm here. I'm sorry I'm doing this. I'm sorry.
我记得她说，我真的很抱歉。对不起。对不起我在这里。对不起我做了这个。对不起。
Mhm.
嗯。
And I don't remember this, but my brother remembers that what she said was, I'm sorry, girls. I'm sorry, girls. And that his whole memory of this night was just being like, I'm a boy. [LAUGHS] He was so mad.
我不记得这个了，但我弟弟记得她所说的是，对不起，女孩们。对不起，女孩们。而他整晚的记忆就是像，我是个男孩。[笑]他太生气了。
And so I ask her-- I said, are you OK? Is everything OK? And that's-- she kept, you know, going on about how her night was so hard.
所以我问她——我说，你还好吗？一切都还好吗？那就是——她继续，你知道，说着她的夜晚有多么艰难。
And I was like, I'm so sorry. That sounds really, really difficult.
我说，我非常抱歉。听起来真的很，真的很困难。
And this is you trying to befriend her.
这就是你试图和她交朋友。
Yeah, this is me trying to befriend her. But it's weird, I feel like-- I was hyper alert to like, if I can understand what's going on with her, I can help solve it. But I couldn't understand, because it didn't make any sense.
对，这就是我试图和她交朋友。但这很奇怪，我觉得——我处于高度戒备状态，如果我能理解她发生了什么，我就能帮忙解决。但我无法理解，因为这完全没有意义。
Did you feel sorry for her?
你为她感到难过吗？
I felt concerned for her.
我为她感到担心。
Yeah.
对。
And-- and then she took out her purse. And she reached into her purse, and then she gripped onto something. And I remember thinking like, oh no, like, what-- the way-- like, if that--
然后她拿出了她的钱包。她把手伸进钱包里，然后抓住了一个东西。我记得我当时心想，哦不，像，如果那——像——
Oh, like, it's like a gun or something.
哦，像，它是枪什么的。
Right, gun, or a knife or something. I remember my heart just dropping. And then she pulled out a hairbrush. And then she just started brushing her hair, like, at the foot of my bed.
对，枪，或刀什么的。我记得我的心沉了下去。然后她掏出一把梳子。然后她就开始在我的床脚梳头发。
Wow.
哇。
And-- and then at that point, I was like, this is really weird. Like, this is like--
在那一刻，我就像，这真的很奇怪。像，这就像——
Right.
对。
And I don't think she's going to leave. And then she sat on the vanity in front of the mirror, at the desk. And she took her earrings off. And--
我不认为她要离开。然后她坐在镜子前的梳妆台上，在桌子旁。她取下了耳环。而且——
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
And she started like-- she took her shoes off. She took her coat off. She was just like--
她开始像——她脱掉鞋子。她脱掉外套。她就像——
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
--making herself comfortable to like, be here now.
——让自己舒服地像，现在要待在这里。
Right.
对。
And so I let her do all that, and was sort of listening to her go on about what was wrong. And then eventually, after I felt like enough time had passed, I said, we have to wake up early to go to school tomorrow. And we're really tired, so I think we should probably go back to bed now.
所以我让她做了所有这些，有点听着她继续说哪里出了问题。最后，在我觉得时间足够了之后，我说，明天我们要早起上学。我们真的很累，所以我想我们现在应该上床睡觉了。
And she was like, I know, I know. I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry I'm here. I'm here. I'm sorry I'm here. And I said, no, it's totally fine that you're here-- almost like, you know, thank you for being here. But do you mind leaving now?
她说，我知道，我知道。对不起，对不起。对不起我在这里。我在这里。对不起我在这里。我说，不，你在这里完全没问题——几乎像，你知道，谢谢你在这里。但你介意现在离开吗？
And so I very slowly stood up and walked over to the door. And every moment was like making sure I was safe. And then I open the door.
所以我非常缓慢地站起来，走到门口。每一刻都像在确保我是安全的。然后我打开门。
And she said, OK, OK. And she put her shoes on, and then she started to leave. And just as she was about to leave, I said, oh, you forgot your earrings. And then she was like-- started crying all over again, like it was this huge thing, walked over to get the earrings, and then sat back down on the bed.
她说，好的，好的。她穿上鞋子，然后开始离开。就在她要离开的时候，我说，哦，你忘了你的耳环。然后她就像——开始又哭起来了，像这是一件大事，走过来拿耳环，然后又在床上坐了下来。
And I remember thinking like, goddamn, why did I bring up the earrings? We were so close to being safe. So then the whole thing-- basically, the whole thing started all over again, where I had to like, listen to her cry, calm her down. And then finally, I'm like, you know, we have to wake up early to go to school. Do you mind leaving?
我记得我想像，该死，我为什么要提耳环？我们离安全那么近。所以整个事情——基本上，整个事情又重新开始了，我不得不像，听她哭，让她平静下来。最后，我说，你知道，我们明天要早起上学。你介意离开吗？
And I walked her to the door. And she walked out of the door. And then as soon as she was out of the door, I just pushed the door as hard as I could to close it. And when I pushed it, like basically slammed it shut, she screamed at the top of her lungs.
我送她到门口。她走出门外。一出门，我就用力推门想关上它。当我推门的时候，像基本上把它重重地关上了，她放声尖叫。
And is there a bolt or something on the door?
门上有什么插销之类的吗？
I think I did bolt it after I slammed it shut.
我想我在重重地关上门后确实锁上了。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And then I heard her screaming in the hallway. And then she ran down the hallway, screaming. And then she ran back towards the door, screaming. And--
然后我听到她在走廊里尖叫。她沿着走廊跑，尖叫着。然后她跑回门边，尖叫着。而且——
That must have been terrifying.
那一定很可怕。
It was so scary. And then-- then it got-- was quiet. And then I heard this loud-- she's like banging on the door, like as hard as she can, right?
那真的很可怕。然后——然后就——安静了。然后我听到这个巨大的——她像在砰砰地敲门，像她能用的最大力气，对吧？
And then I hear a voice, and it's my dad. And my dad's like, open the door. Open the door. And I realize it's not her banging on the door.
然后我听到一个声音，是我爸爸。我爸爸像，开门。开门。我意识到那不是她在敲门。
So I open the door. And my dad's standing there, and he's like, did you hear someone screaming in the hallway? So then I tell him this whole story.
所以我开门。我爸爸站在那里，他说，你听到走廊里有人尖叫了吗？所以我告诉了他整个故事。
I'm like, there was this woman. She was in our room. I tell him all the details. And he is furious. He was so mad.
我就像，有个女人。她在我们的房间里。我告诉了他所有细节。他非常愤怒。他太生气了。
And then he told us to stay there, shut the door, don't open the door. And then he went downstairs and talked to the hotel about it.
然后他叫我们待在那里，关上门，不要开门。然后他下楼和酒店谈论了这件事。
Yeah, what did he learn?
是的，他了解到了什么？
They tell him that she had been outside. She was crying. They asked if she was a guest there. She said yes, her name was Elena Baker. And so they looked up the name.
他们告诉他她刚才在外面。她在哭。他们问她是不是那里的客人。她说是的，她的名字叫埃尔娜·贝克。所以他们查了这个名字。
Elena Baker?
埃尔娜·贝克？
Elena Baker, yeah.
埃尔娜·贝克，是的。
And your name is Elna Baker.
而你的名字是埃尔娜·贝克。
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
But I don't believe this part of the story. I think someone at the hotel just said this to him to cover.
但我不太相信故事的这一部分。我认为酒店里的某个人只是为了掩盖而对他说了这个。
And then they gave her a key?
然后他们给了她一把钥匙？
And then they gave her a key.
然后他们给了她一把钥匙。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Yeah. And so the hotel offered him, you know, the whole stay for free, everything for free. And he's like, I don't care about your money. I want you guys to do a formal investigation as to how this happened.
是的。所以酒店提出给他，你知道，整个住宿免费，所有东西都免费。他像，我不关心你的钱。我想要你们对这件事进行正式调查，弄清楚这是怎么发生的。
Wow, that's such a white-man-takes-charge move.
哇，这是一个很有“白人负责”举动的举动。
My dad's not white.
我爸爸不是白人。
Oh, point taken. [LAUGHS]
哦，重点已收到。[笑]
He's a Hispanic man.
他是一个西班牙裔男人。
I was just thinking, you just never hear like, somebody be like, I demand a formal investigation, you know what I mean? It's like he's a member of Congress or something, you know?
我只是在想，你从来没听过像，有人会像，我要求进行正式调查，你知道我的意思吗？就像他是国会议员什么的，你懂吗？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
All right, anyway--
好的，不管怎样——
But that's what-- I mean, that's totally how my dad would-- like, that's my dad.
但这就是——意思是，这完全是我爸爸会做的——像，那就是我爸爸。
Point taken. OK.
重点已收到。好的。
And so they do a formal investigation, which they then send to my dad. And--
所以他们确实进行了正式调查，后来他们发给我爸爸。而且——
Long after you've like, gone from the hotel.
在你离开酒店很久之后。
Exactly. And in it, there's a picture of the woman. And then there's her history.
正是如此。在里面，有一张那个女人的照片。还有她的历史。
She had been in a psychiatric hospital and escaped that night, come to the hotel. And she had a long history of breaking into people's homes. And he's not certain about this part, so I don't--
她曾住过精神病院，那天晚上逃了出来，来到了酒店。她有很长的入室行窃历史。他不确定这一部分，所以我不——
He doesn't remember it?
他不记得了？
He doesn't remember, but he says that he remembers there being-- she had attacked people when she'd broken into their homes.
他不记得了，但他说是他记得有——她在闯入别人家时袭击过别人。
That's what he remembers?
那是他记得的？
That's what he remembers.
那是他记得的。
Yeah.
是的。
That part of the story-- the investigation, who the woman was-- Elna only found that out a couple of years ago when she asked her dad about it. At the time, back when she was 14, her parents kept all that from her and her brother and sisters. They didn't want them to dwell on it or make them afraid of the world. They didn't want that evening to become a bigger deal than it already was. And Elna says today, that worked.
故事的那部分——调查，那个女人是谁——埃尔娜也是几年前问她爸爸时才知道的。当时，在她14岁的时候，她的父母把这一切都瞒着她和她的兄弟姐妹。他们不想让他们纠结于此，也不想让他们对这个世界感到恐惧。他们不想让那个晚上变成比它已经发生的事情更严重的问题。埃尔娜今天说，这奏效了。
And it's funny, I've-- even as I've told this story over the years, people are like, oh, that's so traumatic, or that's crazy. And I don't think of it like that.
而且很有趣，我——即使我多年来讲述这个故事，人们也像，哦，那太创伤了，或者是疯了。我不这么想。
How so?
怎么说？
It just-- it just was sort of like a-- because nothing bad happened, it has no category for me, if that makes sense. It's been easier-- it was easier to just think like, oh, this one-- this weird thing happened one night when we were in a hotel.
它只是——它只是像是一个——因为没有发生坏事，它对我没有分类，如果这有意义的话。这更容易——更容易只认为是像，哦，这一件——这件奇怪的事情发生在我们住酒店的一个晚上。
In retrospect, would you have preferred if they had told you back when you were 14?
回顾过去，如果你14岁的时候他们告诉了你，你会更喜欢吗？
No, I think it's good that I got to live in a world that I think is safe.
不，我认为好在我能生活在一个我认为是安全的世界里。
On the other hand, she says, if they had made clear how much danger she was in, the family's memory of it and her memory of it wouldn't be of this weird event with no category, this random thing that happened one night. Instead, it would fit squarely into the category called victory-- solid win for 14-year-old girl in a big, religious family, when she got that stranger out of their hotel room without anybody getting hurt. And Elna says she would have liked that win.
另一方面，她说，如果他们清楚地表明她处于多大的危险之中，家人对它的记忆和她的记忆就不会是这个没有分类的怪事，这个一个晚上发生的随机事情。相反，它会直接落入被称为“胜利”的类别——一个巨大的、虔诚的家庭中14岁女孩的坚实胜利，当她把那个陌生人赶出他们的酒店房间而没有人受伤时。埃尔娜说她会喜欢那个胜利。
When you're trapped inside a room with an unpredictable person, really, all you've got is your wits, and your ability to read the situation, and your judgment at guessing what will work. Nice to show everybody that even a kid can make the right call sometimes, if they pay attention closely enough.
当你被困在一个不可预测的人的房间里时，实际上，你所拥有的只有你的智慧，你阅读情况的能力，以及你猜测什么会起作用的判断力。很高兴向大家展示，即使是一个孩子，如果他们足够仔细地观察，有时也能做出正确的决定。
Elna Baker, one of the producers of our show, talking to Ira Glass.
埃尔娜·贝克，我们节目的制作人之一，正在和艾拉·格拉斯交谈。
Act three-- You Can't Go Your Own Way. In her memoir, In the Dream House, Carmen Maria Machado wrote this chapter that's set up like a choose your own adventure story, which I just thought was so smart when I read it. In it, she imagines different choices she could have made with a partner that she's in a bad relationship with-- an abusive relationship.
第三幕——“你不能走自己的路”。在她的回忆录《梦想之屋》（In the Dream House）中，卡门·玛丽亚·马查多写了这一章，其设置就像一个“选择你自己的冒险”故事，我在阅读时觉得这太聪明了。在书中，她想象了如果她和一段糟糕的关系中的伴侣——一段虐待关系——在一起时，她本可以做出的不同选择。
And one of the things it captures is just the mental energy that somebody in that situation can end up putting into trying to figure out what they should do or not do to avoid setting off their partner. A heads up that this excerpt includes a scene with sexual content. It's read for us by actor Zoe Winters.
它捕捉到的其中一点，是一个处于那种境地的人最终可能投入的心理能量，去试图弄清楚他们应该做什么或不应该做什么，以避免触怒他们的伴侣。提醒一下，这段节选包含性内容。由演员佐伊·温特斯为我们朗读。
Page one. You wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself, this is the kind of morning you could get used to.
第一页。你醒了，空气奶白色明亮。房间里洋溢着一种冒泡的满足感，尽管有纸箱、衣服和盘子。你心想，这是你可以习惯的那种早晨。
When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
当你翻身时，她盯着你看。光线的明亮纯真在你的胃里凝固。你不记得曾经如此迅速地从清醒变得恐惧。
You were moving all night, she says. Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake.
你整晚都在动，她说。你的手臂和肘部碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。
If you apologize profusely, go to page two. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page three. If you tell her to calm down, go to page five.
如果你深表歉意，转到第二页。如果你告诉她下次你的肘部在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，转到第三页。如果你叫她冷静点，转到第五页。
I choose page two. Page two-- I'm so sorry, you tell her. I really didn't mean to. I just move my arms around a lot in my sleep.
我选择第二页。第二页——我非常抱歉，你告诉她。我真的不是故意的。我只是睡着时手臂动得太多。
You try to be light about it. Did you know my dad does the same thing? The sleeping damsel swoon. So weird. I must have--
你试图轻松一点。你知道我爸爸也这样吗？沉睡淑女的晕厥。太奇怪了。我一定——
Are you really sorry? She says. I don't think you are. I am, you say.
你是真的抱歉吗？她说。我不认为你是。我是，你说。
You want the first impression of the morning to return to you-- its freshness, its light. I really am. Prove it. How? Stop doing it.
你希望早晨的第一印象回到你身边——它的新鲜，它的光亮。我真的是。证明它。怎么做？别再做了。
I told you, I can't. Fuck you, she says, and gets out of bed. You follow her all the way to the kitchen. Go to page seven.
我告诉你了，我不能。去你的，她说，然后起床。你一直跟着她到厨房。转到第七页。
Page seven-- breakfast. You scramble some eggs, make some toast. She eats mechanically and leaves the plate on the table. Clean that up, she says, as she goes to the bedroom to get dressed.
第七页——早餐。你炒了一些鸡蛋，做了些烤面包。她机械地吃着，把盘子留在桌上。清理那个，她说，然后去卧室穿衣服。
If you stare mutely at the dirty plate, and all you can think about is Clara Barton, the feminist icon of your youth, who had to teach herself how to be a nurse, and endured abuse from men telling her what to do at every turn, and you remember being so angry, and running to your parents and asking them if women still got told what was right or proper, and your mom said yes, and your dad said no, and you, for the first time, had an inkling of how complicated and terrible the world was, go to page 10. If you do as you are told, go to page eight. If you tell her to do it herself, go to page five.
如果你呆滞地盯着脏盘子，你所能想到的只有克拉拉·巴顿（Clara Barton），你年轻时的女权主义偶像，她必须自学如何成为护士，并忍受男人的虐待，在每一个转弯处告诉她做什么，你记得当时非常生气，跑去问你父母女性是否仍然被告知什么是正确或适当的，你妈妈说是的，你爸爸说不，而你，第一次隐约感觉到世界是多么复杂和可怕，转到第十页。如果你照做，转到第八页。如果你告诉她自己做，转到第五页。
Page five-- are you kidding? You'd never do this. Don't try to convince any of these people that you'd stand up for yourself for one second. Get out of here. Go to the next chapter. You're out.
第五页——你在开玩笑吗？你永远不会这样做。不要试图说服这些人你会为你自己站出来哪怕一秒钟。离开这里。转到下一章。你出局了。
Wait, no, let's try that again. I go to page eight. Page eight-- as you're washing the dishes, you think to yourself, maybe I should put a tack on my forehead. Maybe I should be a better person. Go to page one.
等等，不，让我们再试一次。我转到第八页。第八页——当你洗碗时，你心想，也许我应该在额头上贴个图钉。也许我应该成为一个更好的人。转到第一页。
Page one-- you wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself, this is the kind of morning you could get used to.
第一页——你醒了，空气奶白色明亮。房间里洋溢着一种冒泡的满足感，尽管有纸箱、衣服和盘子。你心想，这是你可以习惯的那种早晨。
When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
当你翻身时，她盯着你看。光线的明亮纯真在你的胃里凝固。你不记得曾经如此迅速地从清醒变得恐惧。
You were moving all night, she says. Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake.
你整晚都在动，她说。你的手臂和肘部碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。
If you apologize profusely, go to page two. If you tell her to calm down, go to page five. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page three.
如果你深表歉意，转到第二页。如果你叫她冷静点，转到第五页。如果你告诉她下次你的肘部在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，转到第三页。
I go to page three. Page three-- baby, if this ever happens in the future, you can always wake me up, and I'll go to the couch, I promise. I really don't mean to do it. I don't have any memory of it. I can't control how I move in my sleep.
我转到第三页。第三页——宝贝，如果这种情况将来发生，你随时都可以叫醒我，我会去沙发上睡，我保证。我真的不是故意做的。我对此没有任何记忆。我无法控制我睡着时如何移动。
You are such a fucking cunt, she says. You never take responsibility for anything. All you have to do is wake me up, you say, a kind of incoherent desperation zipping through your skull. That's it. Wake me up and tell me to move or sleep on the couch, and I will do it. I swear to you.
你真是个该死的荡妇，她说。你从来不为任何事负责。你只要叫醒我就行了，你说，一种混乱的绝望感在你的头骨里飞速穿梭。就是那样。叫醒我，告诉我移动或睡在沙发上，我会做的。我向你发誓。
Fuck you, she says, and gets out of bed. You follow her to the kitchen. Go to page seven.
去你的，她说，然后起床。你跟着她到厨房。转到第七页。
Page seven-- breakfast. You scramble some eggs, make some toast. She eats mechanically and leaves the plate on the table. Clean that up, she says, as she goes to the bedroom to get dressed.
第七页——早餐。你炒了一些鸡蛋，做了些烤面包。她机械地吃着，把盘子留在桌上。清理那个，她说，然后去卧室穿衣服。
If you do as you are told, go to page eight. If you tell her to do it herself, go to page five. If you stare mutely at the dirty plate, and all you can think about is Clara Barton, the feminist icon of your youth, who had to teach herself how to be a nurse, and endured abuse from men telling her what to do at every turn, and you remember being so angry, and running to your parents and asking them if women still got told what was right or proper, and your mom said yes, and your dad said no, and you, for the first time, had an inkling of how complicated and terrible the world was, go to page 10.
如果你照做，转到第八页。如果你告诉她自己做，转到第五页。如果你呆滞地盯着脏盘子，你所能想到的只有克拉拉·巴顿，你年轻时的女权主义偶像，她必须自学如何成为护士，并忍受男人的虐待，在每一个转弯处告诉她做什么，你记得当时非常生气，跑去问你父母女性是否仍然被告知什么是正确或适当的，你妈妈说是的，你爸爸说不，而你，第一次隐约感觉到世界是多么复杂和可怕，转到第十页。
Page 10-- that night, she [MUTED] you as you lie there mutely, praying for it to be over, praying she won't notice you're gone. You have voided your body so many times by now that it is force of habit, reflexive as a sigh. It reminds you of your first boyfriend, who [MUTED] you while watching porn, how he rutted and rutted, and then every so often, lifted the remote to rewind something you couldn't see.
第十页——那天晚上，她[消音]你，当你呆滞地躺在那里，祈祷它早点结束，祈祷她不会注意到你离开了。你已经多次清空了你的身体，以至于这成了习惯，像叹息一样条件反射。它让我想起了我的第一个男朋友，他一边看色情片一边[消音]我，他怎么不断地摩擦，然后每隔一段时间，举起遥控器倒回一些你看不到的东西。
Once, you turned your head over the lip of the bed and saw a tangle of upside-down limbs, and your brain couldn't make sense of them. You never looked again. You would just lie there silently, watching his face move over you. It was like being unfolded beneath the yawn of the planetarium as a kid-- the sped-up rotation of the Earth, the movement of the stars, the constellations melting into and out of being.
有一次，你把头伸过床沿，看到了倒置的四肢纠缠在一起，你的大脑无法理解它们。你再也没有看过。你只会默默地躺在那里，看着他的脸在你身上移动。就像小时候被展开在天文馆的巨大穹顶下一样——地球旋转的加速，星星的运动，星座融化成存在和不存在。
You shudder and moan with precision. She turns off the lights. You watch the darkness until the darkness leaves you, or you leave it.
你颤抖并精确地呻吟。她关掉灯。你看着黑暗，直到黑暗离开你，或者你离开它。
To sleep, go to page 14. To dream about the present, go to page 13. To dream about the future, go to page 12.
要睡觉，转到第十四页。要梦到过去的你，转到第十一页。要梦到现在的你，转到第十三页。
To dream about the past, go to page 11. I want to dream about the past. I choose page 11.
要梦到过去的你，转到第十一页。我想梦到过去。我选择第十一页。
Page 11-- the first time it happened. The first time she yelled at you so much you were crying within 30 seconds from waking-- a record. She said, the first 10 minutes of the day, I'm not responsible for anything I say. This struck you as poetic. You even wrote it down, sure you would find a place for it in a book, maybe. Go to page 14.
第十一页——第一次发生这件事。第一次她对你大喊大叫，以至于你从醒来开始就在30秒内哭了——一个记录。她说，一天的前10分钟，我对我说的一切都不负责。这让你觉得很有诗意。你甚至把它写了下来，确信你会为它找到一个位置，也许在一本书里。转到第十四页。
Page 9-- you shouldn't be on this page. There's no way to get here from the choices given to you. Do you think that, by flipping through this chapter linearly, you'd find some kind of relief? Don't you get it? All of this shit already happened. And you can't make it not happen, no matter what you do.
第九页——你不应该在这页。从给你提供的选择中，没有办法来到这里。你认为通过线性翻阅这一章，你会找到某种解脱吗？你还不明白吗？所有这些狗屎都已经发生了。无论你做什么，你都无法让它不发生。
Do you want a picture of a fawn? Will that help? OK, here's a fawn. She is small, and dappled, and loose-legged.
你想要一张小鹿的照片吗？那会有帮助吗？好的，这是一只小鹿。她是小的，斑点的，腿很松。
She hears a sound, freezes, and then bolts. She knows what to do. She knows there's somewhere safer she can be. Go to page 10.
她听到一个声音，冻住了，然后跑了。她知道该怎么做。她知道有一个更安全的地方她可以待着。转到第十页。
I don't want to go to page 10. Page 6-- you shouldn't be on this page. There's no way to get here from the choices given to you. You flipped here because you got sick of the cycle.
我不想去第十页。第六页——你不应该在这页。从给你提供的选择中，没有办法来到这里。你翻到这里是因为你厌倦了这个循环。
You wanted to get out. You're smarter than me. Go to page 10.
你想脱身。你比我聪明。转到第十页。
Fine. I go to page 10. Page 10-- that night, she fucks you as you lie there mutely, praying for it to be over, praying she won't notice you're gone. You have voided your body so many times by now that it is force of habit, reflexive as a sigh.
好的。我转到第十页。第十页——那天晚上，她操你，当你呆滞地躺在那里，祈祷它早点结束，祈祷她不会注意到你离开了。你已经多次清空了你的身体，以至于这成了习惯，像叹息一样条件反射。
It reminds you of your first-- the sped-up rotation of the Earth, the movement of the stars, the constellations melting into and out of being. You shudder and moan with precision. She turns off the lights. You watch the darkness until the darkness leaves you, or you leave it.
它让我想起了我的第一个——地球旋转的加速，星星的运动，星座融化成存在和不存在。你颤抖并精确地呻吟。她关掉灯。你看着黑暗，直到黑暗离开你，或者你离开它。
To sleep, go to page 14. To dream about the past, go to page 11. To dream about the present, go to page 13.
若要睡觉，请翻到第14页。若要梦见过去，请翻到第11页。若要梦见现在，请翻到第13页。
Page 13-- you shouldn't be here, but it's OK. It's a dream. She can't find you here. In a minute, you're going to wake up, and everything is going to seem like it's the same, but it's not.
第十三页——你不应该在这里，但没关系。这是一个梦。她在这里找不到你。一分钟后，你会醒来，一切看起来都一样，但不是这样。
There's a way out. Are you listening to me? You can't forget when you wake up. You can't go to page 14.
有一条出路。你在听我说话吗？醒来时你不能忘记。你不能转到第十四页。
I want to dream about the future. I go to page 12. Page 12-- it's going to be all right.
我想梦到未来。我转到第十二页。第十二页——一切都会好的。
One day, your wife will gently adjust your arm if it touches her face at night, soothingly straightening it while kissing you. Sometimes, you will wake up just enough to notice. Other times, she'll only tell you in the morning. It's the kind of morning you could get used to. Go to page 14.
有一天，你的妻子会温柔地调整你的手臂，如果它在晚上碰到她的脸，舒缓地拉直它，同时吻你。有时，你会醒来刚好注意到。其他时候，她只会在早晨告诉你。这是你可以习惯的那种早晨。转到第十四页。
Page 14-- you wake up, and the air is milky and bright. The room glows with a kind of effervescent contentment, despite the boxes, and clothes, and dishes. You think to yourself, this is the kind of morning you could get used to.
第十四页——你醒了，空气奶白色明亮。房间里洋溢着一种冒泡的满足感，尽管有纸箱、衣服和盘子。你心想，这是你可以习惯的那种早晨。
When you turn over, she is staring at you. The luminous innocence of the light curdles in your stomach. You don't remember ever going from awake to afraid so quickly.
当你翻身时，她盯着你看。光线的明亮纯真在你的胃里凝固。你不记得曾经如此迅速地从清醒变得恐惧。
You were moving all night, she says. Your arms and elbows touched me. You kept me awake.
你整晚都在动，她说。你的手臂和肘部碰到了我。你让我无法入睡。
If you apologize profusely, go to page two. If you tell her to wake you up next time your elbows touch her in your sleep, go to page three. If you toss back the blankets from your body and hit the floor with both feet, and tear through the house like it's Pamplona, and when you get to the driveway, your car keys are already in your hand, and you drive away with a theatrical squeal of the tires, never to return again, go to page 15.
如果你深表歉意，转到第二页。如果你告诉她下次你的肘部在睡梦中碰到她时叫醒你，转到第三页。如果你从身上踢开毯子，两只脚着地，像在潘普洛纳一样在房子里横冲直撞，当你到达车道时，车钥匙已经在你手里，你带着剧烈的轮胎摩擦声开车离开，再也没有回来，转到第十五页。
Page 15-- that's not how it happened, but OK, we can pretend. I'll give it to you, just this once. Turn to page 16.
第十五页——事情不是那样发生的，但好吧，我们可以假装。我给你这个机会，就这一次。翻到第十六页。
Page 16-- an end. In the pit of it, you fantasize about dying-- tripping on a sidewalk, and stumbling into the path of an oncoming car, a gas leak silently offing you in your sleep, a machete-wielding madman on public transit, falling down the stairs, but drunk, so you flop, limb over limb, like a marionette, and feel no pain-- anything to make it stop. You have forgotten that leaving is an option.
第十六页——一个结局。在深渊中，你幻想死亡——在人行道上绊倒，跌入迎面而来的车道，睡觉时漏出的煤气静静地杀死你，公共交通工具上的持刀疯子，从楼梯上跌倒，但喝醉了，所以你像木偶一样肢体瘫软，感觉不到痛苦——任何事情只要能让它停止。你已经忘记离开是一个选择。
Zoe Winters reading a chapter from Carmen Maria Machado's memoir, In the Dream House. Carmen has a comic series out now called The Low, Low Woods, from DC Comics. You can see Zoe Winters in season three of HBO'S Succession, which is out in October.
佐伊·温特斯朗读卡门·玛丽亚·马查多回忆录《梦想之屋》中的一章。卡门现在有一部名为《低，低林》（The Low, Low Woods）的漫画系列，由DC漫画出版。你可以在HBO的《继承之战》第三季中看到佐伊·温特斯，该剧于10月播出。
Act four-- Blue Kid on the Block. This last story is about what happens after you get out-- in this particular case, when you get out of Rochester, New York. The kid in this story, who we're going to call Leo-- it's not his real name-- his family had moved to an entirely different state. And he was not happy about it.
第四幕——“街区的蓝色小孩”。最后一个故事是关于你脱身之后发生的事情——在这个特殊的例子中，当你离开纽约州罗切斯特的时候。在这个故事里，我们称之为“利奥”（Leo）的孩子——这不是他的真名——他的家人搬到了一个完全不同的州。而他对此并不高兴。
At the time, Leo was just starting seventh grade. He was having a harder time finding his place in middle school than other middle school kids, because, you know, he was new to town, but also because Leo still loved Rochester. He loved his school there. He loved his friends. Suddenly, everything about his life was different, and according to Leo, much worse.
当时，利奥刚开始读七年级。他比其他初中生更难在学校找到自己的位置，因为，你知道，他是镇上的新人，但也因为利奥仍然热爱罗切斯特。他热爱他在那里的学校。他热爱他的朋友。突然之间，他生活的一切都不同了，而且根据利奥的说法，更糟了。
The signature on his Gmail account now read, Rochester is much better, in big, red letters. Sarah Koenig knows Leo and his parents. She visited them at home to see how Leo is doing.
他Gmail账户上的签名现在写着，罗切斯特好得多，用的是大大的红字。莎拉·柯尼希认识利奥和他的父母。她到他们家拜访，看看利奥过得怎么样。
This is how much Leo does not want to be here-- when I got to his house, he was on the sofa with a laptop, investigating Greyhound bus schedules. His mother was going to drive him and his sister back to Rochester for the Columbus Day weekend, but not until Saturday morning. And Leo wanted to get there Friday for more time with his friends.
这就是利奥有多不想待在这里的程度——当我到达他家时，他正坐在沙发上用笔记本电脑，调查灰狗巴士的时间表。他妈妈要在哥伦布日周末带他和妹妹回罗切斯特，但要到周六早上才走。而利奥想在周五到达那里，好和朋友多待一会儿。
A multi-stage negotiation followed with his dad. For one thing, a bus ticket costs money.
随后他和他爸爸进行了多阶段的谈判。首先，一张巴士票要钱。
That's not the-- that's not a problem. [? I have that money-- ?]
那不是——那不是问题。[？我有那笔钱——？]
Not for you. No, that wasn't a problem for you.
不是你。不，那对你来说不是问题。
No, but--
不，但是——
There isn't one, right?
没有，对吧？
There isn't one-- not at 6:15 in the morning. And you won't let me miss school on Friday.
没有——早上6:15没有。而且你不会让我周五错过上学。
The bus takes eight hours. Even if you left at noon, you'd be at-- are gonna do the math? That's excellent.
巴士要走八个小时。即使你中午走，你也会在——是要做数学计算吗？那很好。
Never mind that the bus takes twice as long as driving, and never mind that Leo would be alone, and have to change buses, and that his parents had no intention of letting him go through with this plan. But it's the kind of negotiation you indulge when your kid is miserable. And Leo is miserable. He told me right away he was, and that he had been from the moment he got here in August.
别管巴士需要的时间是开车两倍，别管利奥会一个人，必须换乘巴士，也别管他父母根本没打算让他实行这个计划。但这是当你孩子痛苦时你纵容的那种谈判。而且利奥非常痛苦。他立刻告诉了我，他从八月份来到这里的那一刻起就是如此。
Is this the first time you've-- in your life where you felt like you've been sad about something for this long?
这是你生活中第一次感到因为某事难过这么久吗？
I think so, except for maybe when my other cat died-- my old cat.
我想是吧，除了可能是我另一只猫死的时候——我以前的那只猫。
And does this feel worse than that?
这感觉比那次更糟吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Mhm. I've never had long periods of sad until now. I don't know. I don't know anyone here, really. And I think it's just everything in general that's overwhelming.
嗯哼。我直到现在才有过长时间的难过。我不知道。我真的不认识这里的人。我认为这只是普遍的一切都让人不知所措。
Back in Rochester, Leo had known all his best friends since kindergarten or before. They played together at school, after school, on weekends. Everybody knew everybody. Everything was comfortable.
回到罗切斯特，利奥从幼儿园或更早的时候就认识了他所有的好朋友。他们在学校、放学后、周末一起玩。每个人都认识每个人。一切都很舒服。
And as a sixth grader in his old school, he and his friends were at the top of the heap. They wore green sashes in the morning, and got to be door monitors for the younger kids coming into the building. So imagine now, Leo takes a school bus for the first time to his new school, a sprawling one-story building full of sixth, seventh, and eighth graders.
而且作为他老学校的六年级学生，他和他的朋友们处于顶端。他们早上戴着绿色腰带，成为低年级学生进入大楼的门卫。所以现在想象一下，利奥第一次坐校车去他的新学校，一栋庞大的单层建筑，满是六年级、七年级和八年级学生。
Leo's small for his age, only a hair taller than his sister, who's only nine years old. On day one, he knows exactly no one.
利奥年纪小，只比他九岁的妹妹高一点点。第一天，他谁也不认识。
It was much louder than my old school, much louder. People talking, people closing and opening lockers. People walking-- it was just noise. Just older kids, more kids, because my old school was tiny.
它比我老学校吵多了，吵多了。人们说话，人们关开储物柜。人们走路——全是噪音。只是大孩子，更多的孩子，因为我老学校太小了。
Leo is between. He's old enough to decipher Greyhound bus schedules, but not old enough to actually travel on one by himself, and old enough to know that, if he's going to survive in middle school, he has to make friends, but that making those friends stands to be significantly more complicated than it was back in Rochester. Leo's sister, Auden, is in fourth grade. He says she's not having as hard a time of it.
利奥处于中间。他足够大到能破解灰狗巴士的时间表，但又不够大到能自己一个人乘坐，而且足够大到知道如果他要在初中生存，他就必须交朋友，但交朋友看起来要比在罗切斯特复杂得多。利奥的妹妹奥登（Auden）读四年级。他说她没那么难过。
She hasn't been alive as long. She hasn't made as deep connections. And she's already met some-- a friend in her school. I think it's easier to make friends in elementary school than in middle school.
她活的时间还没那么长。她还没建立那么深的联系。而且她已经遇到了一些——在学校的一个朋友。我认为小学比初中更容易交朋友。
Oh, really? Why?
哦，真的吗？为什么？
Because people care less about who you are.
因为人们不太在乎你是谁。
What do you mean by that?
你那是什么意思？
The older you get, the more you judge people on their looks, their background, their-- how they act, like, what cool is for kids. Because in kindergarten, you could just walk up to someone and say, do you want to be my friend? And they would-- then, that would be it. But it's harder.
你年纪越大，你就越根据外表、背景、他们——他们如何行事来评价人，像，什么对孩子来说是酷的。因为在幼儿园，你只要走到某人面前说，你想成为我的朋友吗？他们就会——那么，这就行了。但很难。
I just think people are more wary before they open up. They like-- I don't know, in first grade, if I met someone, I wouldn't really care who they were. I would just care if they were nice or not.
我只是认为人们在敞开心扉之前更谨慎。他们喜欢——我不知道，在一年级，如果我见到某人，我真的不在乎他们是谁。我只关心他们是否善良。
The day I interviewed him, Leo had had a couple of breakthroughs. He emailed his parents during the school day to tell them the first piece of good news they'd had from him. Until that day, the emails had mostly been three desperate words-- I feel awful. Without even a period at the end to make the feeling finite, it was an endless awful.
我采访他的那天，利奥取得了一些突破。他在上学期间给父母发电子邮件，告诉他们他从他那里听到的第一个好消息。在那天之前，邮件大多是三个绝望的词——我感觉很糟糕。甚至连结尾的句号都没有，让那种感觉显得没完没了，真是无尽的糟糕。
But on this Thursday, he wrote to tell them the mashed potatoes they serve in the cafeteria were great, followed by four exclamation points. Second-- and this was the big news-- he asked another kid if he wanted to come over. Leo told me he thought about it first for a few days, then finally emailed the boy, whose name is Devin, another seventh grader.
但在这周四，他写信告诉他们自助餐厅供应的土豆泥很棒，后面跟着四个感叹号。第二——这是大新闻——他问另一个孩子是否想过来。利奥告诉我想了好几天，最后才发邮件给那个男孩，他的名字叫德文（Devin），也是七年级学生。
But now, Leo didn't want to call Devin's house to finalize a plan. He dreaded the awkwardness of the phone. So his dad called Devin's parents, introduced himself as Leo's father.
但现在，利奥不想打电话给德文家来确定计划。他害怕电话的尴尬。所以他爸爸给德文的父母打了电话，介绍了自己是利奥的父亲。
--dad. He goes to school with your son, Evan. And we were-- Devin-- I'm so sorry, Devin. I'm getting the evil look from my son. I apologize. But we're hoping Devin can come over on Sunday. Thanks. I panicked.
——爸爸。他和你的儿子埃文（Evan）一起上学。我们当时——德文——我真的很抱歉，德文。我从我儿子那里得到了邪恶的目光。我道歉。但我们希望德文周日能过来。谢谢。我慌了。
Dad, you fool! [LAUGHS]
爸爸，你这个傻瓜！[笑]
How'd that go?
进行得怎么样？
Not well.
不太好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is my son, Freddy.
这是我的儿子，弗雷迪（Freddy）。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I thought Leo might be upset about it, maybe get sulky. But here he was, cracking up, joking with his dad. It was such a relief to hear him laugh after he'd been so solemn in our interview.
我以为利奥可能会为此感到不安，可能会变得闷闷不乐。但他就在这里，开怀大笑，和他爸爸开玩笑。在他采访中表现得那么严肃之后听到他的笑声真是一种解脱。
And I thought, this is all going to be OK. He's going to snap out of it. He's almost there. An afternoon with Devin is going to do the trick. Then, Sunday came.
我心想，这一切都会好的。他会走出来的。他快到了。一个和德文待在一起的下午会奏效的。然后，周日到了。
OK, now I have three health again.
好的，现在我又有三点健康了。
I can tell your-- you could tell your wolf to attack.
我可以告诉你的——你可以告诉你的狼进攻。
OK, I'm going to tell my wolf to attack, then.
好的，我要告诉我的狼进攻，然后。
Leo taught Devin how to play Dungeons and Dragons.
利奥教德文怎么玩《龙与地下城》。
And the wolf lands on its feet.
狼着地了。
Yay! Go, wolfie! Go, wolfie!
耶！去吧，小狼！去吧，小狼！
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Go, wolfie! Oh, I am so weird.
去吧，小狼！哦，我真是太奇怪了。
On the drive home, Leo and Devin talk nonstop-- a gentle, rat-a-tat one-upmanship emanating from deep inside a computer game.
在回家的路上，利奥和德文不停地说话——一种温和的、急促的竞争，从电脑游戏深处散发出来。
I am a-- I am what else, warlock?
我是个——我还是什么，术士？
Warlocks are fun. Can you summon your imp yet?
术士很有趣。你能召唤你的小鬼了吗？
Yeah, you start with imp.
是的，你从召唤小鬼开始。
Oh, right. I like-- I had a goblin shaman.
哦，对。我喜欢——我以前有个地精萨满。
I have a night elf druid. And I can turn into a cat at level eight, which is nice.
我有一个暗夜精灵德鲁伊。而且我8级时可以变成一只猫，这很不错。
And at level 12, you get a bear.
而且在12级时，你会得到一头熊。
Yeah.
是的。
And then at level--
而且然后在——级时——
By the time they drop Devin off, they were giggling.
当他们放下德文时，他们正在咯咯笑。
--yeah, you start with--
——是的，你从——开始。
That's funny.
那很有趣。
Our cat responds to whatever you call him. [? And he ?] [? said, ?] his name is Pippen, but we can call him Football, and he'll respond.
我们的猫对你叫他什么都有反应。[？而且他说，？]他的名字叫皮蓬（Pippen），但我们可以叫他足球（Football），他会有反应。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You call him Football?
你叫他足球？
Here, Football! Here, Football!
来，足球！来，足球！
Thanks for coming over.
谢谢你过来。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you for inviting me.
谢谢你邀请我。
See you tomorrow.
明天见。
See you.
再见。
So a perfect day, right? Leo's parents were relieved, hopeful. But no.
所以是完美的一天，对吧？利奥的父母松了一口气，充满希望。但没有。
It's Wednesday. You had your friend over on Sunday. How'd it go?
今天是周三。你周日有朋友过来。进行得怎么样？
It went OK. Yeah, it went OK.
还行。是的，还可以。
Has it changed anything about being here?
这改变了待在这里的任何事情吗？
A little bit. I don't think very much. But a little bit, yeah.
一点点。我觉得不多。但一点点，是的。
What's changed? What's the little bit?
什么改变了？那一点点是什么？
That I know someone at school. It helps. Not all that much, but sort of, yeah.
我在学校认识某人了。这有帮助。没有那么多，但有点，是的。
And this is when I realized I'd underestimated the depth of Leo's gloom-- that he greets every morning of every school day with dread, and not because he's being bullied, or anyone's being mean to him.
就是这时我意识到我低估了利奥悲伤的深度——他迎接每一个上学日的早晨都充满恐惧，并不是因为他被欺负，或者有人对他刻薄。
I feel sick, because I know that I have the whole day ahead of me, and then I have the next day, and the next day, and the next day, and the next day, and the next day ahead of me.
我感到恶心，因为我知道我整天都在面前，然后我还有明天，明天，明天，明天，明天，面前的明天。
Does it pass once you get to school?
当你去学校时会过去吗？
No, not really. It usually increases to a climax around lunchtime. And then I-- actually, I've been throwing up recently. And then it just stays at that level of sickness until I get home.
不，并不是真的。通常在午餐时间增加到高潮。然后我——事实上，我最近一直在呕吐。然后那种恶心的程度就一直保持那个水平直到我回家。
You're kidding me. You're throwing up at school?
你在开玩笑吧。你在学校呕吐？
Yeah.
是的。
Aw, that's awful. In the bathroom, or where?
啊，这太糟糕了。在洗手间，或者哪里？
Yeah, in the bathroom. Usually at lunch, I feel really bad. And then I go to the bathroom, and I throw up.
是的，在洗手间。通常在午餐时，我感觉非常糟糕。然后我去洗手间，我呕吐。
Has that happened this week?
这周发生过吗？
Today, it did.
今天发生了。
Do you tell your parents like, I don't want to go, I don't want to go? Or do you just-- you know you have to, so you don't say anything?
你告诉父母像，我不想去，我不想去吗？还是你只是——你知道你必须去，所以你什么都不说？
No, I throw a screaming fit.
不，我发了歇斯底里的疯。
Every morning?
每天早上？
Yeah, pretty much. I didn't today.
是的，差不多。今天没有。
What was different about this morning? How come you didn't today?
今天早上有什么不同？你今天为什么没发疯？
I felt resigned. I mean, I knew that I would have to go anyway, so I gave up.
我感到顺从。意思是，我知道无论如何我都要去，所以我放弃了。
Here's the curse of being almost 13-- old enough to understand his life will supposedly get better with time, but not old enough to really believe he's going to feel any differently than he does right this minute. Since making friends with Devin, Leo is one step toward being the kid he wants to be-- someone with pals, someone who's comfortable again. But he says right now, he's just worried he's going to be throwing up all year.
这就是快13岁的诅咒——足够理解他的生活理应随着时间变得更好，但又不够大到真的相信他会感到和此时此刻有任何不同。自从和德文交朋友后，利奥离成为他想成为的孩子近了一步——一个有伙伴的孩子，一个再次感到舒服的孩子。但他现在说，他只是担心他会整年都在呕吐。
Sarah Koenig-- she's the host of Serial. In the years since this story first ran, Leo has made many friends. They've become immersed in the world of theater, and has finally forgiven their parents for the move. Leo did return to New York, though. They graduated from NYU this past spring.
莎拉·柯尼希——她是《串行》（Serial）的主持人。在这个故事第一次播出后的几年里，利奥交了很多朋友。他们沉浸在戏剧世界中，终于原谅了父母的搬家。不过，利奥确实回到了纽约。他们今年春天从纽约大学毕业。
[MUSIC - "WE GOTTA GET OUT OF THIS PLACE" BY THE ANIMALS]
[音乐 - 动物乐队（The Animals）的《我们得离开这个地方》（WE GOTTA GET OUT OF THIS PLACE）]
(SINGING) We gotta get out of this place if it's the last thing we ever do. We gotta get out of this place. 'Cause girl, there's a better life for me and you.
（演唱）我们得离开这个地方，如果这是我们最后能做的事。我们得离开这个地方。因为女孩，有一个更好的生活等着我和你。
Today's program was produced by Diane Wu and Lina Misitzis. The people who put the show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Chloee Weiner. Our managing editor-- Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Harrison Nesbit, Will Yurman, Hilary Appleman, and Maximo Berryman-Chace.
今天的节目由黛安·吴和莉娜·米西齐斯制作。今天把节目拼凑在一起的人包括宾·阿德翁米、埃尔娜·贝克、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、塞斯·林德、斯托·纳尔逊、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和克洛伊·温纳。我们的总编辑——莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢哈里森·内斯比特、威尔·尤尔曼、希拉里·阿普尔曼和马克西莫·贝里曼-蔡斯。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过700集的档案。再说一次，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心PRX提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks to our boss, Ira Glass. You know, he says he's on vacation, but he keeps coming into the studio, making these tiny little edits to our stories.
感谢我们的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。你知道，他说他在度假，但他一直在进录音室，对我们的故事做这些微小的编辑。
I'm really sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry I'm here. I'm sorry I'm doing this. I'm sorry.
我真的很抱歉。对不起。对不起我在这里。对不起我做了这个。对不起。
We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
(SINGING) Girl, there's a better life for me and you. Somewhere, baby. Somehow, I know it, baby. We got to get out of this place if it's the last thing we ever do.
（演唱）女孩，有一个更好的生活等着我和你。某个地方，宝贝。不知何故，我知道，宝贝。我们得离开这个地方，如果这是我们最后能做的事。